they're giving weed away to poor people
in berkeley california yeah that's right
we've got a little more info for you
marijuana dispensaries will be required
to give two percent of their pot to
people earning less than thirty two
thousand dollars per year the measure is
destined to provide pain relief to the
needy who cannot afford prices that
reach four hundred dollars for an ounce
of legalized weed the regulation was
passed last month by the City Council it
takes effect next summer I want to give
a shout out to our director Mike who got
very excited when we showed that right
there um okay look we do a lot of weed
stuff here I smoke weed I have no
problem with we'd like the weed you know
once I did it once I'd you got it I'm
high right now oh yeah just once just
one this one's for you one marijuana for
you and I would imagine since you got
rid of your dreads now I'm clean you're
totally clean slate yeah ok so there's
just something kind of funny about this
story I guess in general like that the
government would be giving weed to poor
people so let's just get the funny stuff
out know what you don't like is there
something funny about this there's
something funny right like we need to
poor people I mean it's medical
marijuana so it's well you technically
supposed to be serving a purpose yeah
medically right I mean you know so
you're trying to help people out but the
only the only issue I kind of had what
this was forcing businesses to give away
two percent of you know their product
which you wouldn't normally do but I
heard from a bird through the grapevine
that sometimes when you go to these
places they give you free joint anyway
so might not be so bad yeah it's only
might do that yeah they told you you
never know so getting away from the
funny part of like just yeah I just add
this vision of like there would be
homeless people that we just be getting
them stoned all day that just seems
funny to me somehow good think about it
this way I mean we either state aid
given to these two poor people who can
go in and get prescriptions filled there
are things that are way more serious you
known archons like a you know oxys or
adderall or you know things that really
can affect people and a really good
stuff not just really good like we
didn't like a but if I'm like not hang
out
I mean seriously like this is and these
are medically these are regulated things
that large companies make a tremendous
amount of money on still you know with
these people coming in with their state
insurance and I feel like this innocence
is amazing because it's taking big
business out of it and I i think that's
that's making huge strides in the whole
industry in general yeah narcotics is
one of the number one killers of acts
like accidental deaths in America you
know so for people to be worried about
marijuana that hasn't told anyone ever
write everything you know sounds like a
giant wanna like face-planted and I've
never liked died from that obviously cuz
I'm sitting right there if I ever smoked
weed that was depleting you I would
reduce no collateral a RN I mean where
every time we do a weed story we talk
about that that uh that right people
don't die of weed it's just they don't
they don't even get into car accidents
because of weed they sit there and they
eat and they laugh and that's it that's
the bigger concern I'd be more concerned
on people wasting their food snaps much
faster I get it it's about to get
serious so what are the people that
would argue it's gonna kill their
motivation because there is probably
some truth to that you could smoke weed
and you sit there and watch cartoons
instead of going to get a job and doing
what you should do to be a productive
member of society yeah I was watching a
debate on fox news about this and that's
exactly what the pastor was saying what
are we gonna we're gonna we're gonna
make all these people out there who
don't have a job even more lazy yeah
yeah I mean I mean if they weren't doing
things before they're probably not gonna
do less things now because they're high
you know before maybe maybe they'll
start thinking outside of the box why
people homeless or poor they're there in
these situations because of you know
medical problems that they have or other
problems in their life it's not just
because they're lazy and that's a big
misunderstanding of what people have
they stigmatize you know people who are
lower income and they call them lazy
when that's not the case right
one-hundred percent agree on a serious
level of this and medical marijuana
actually does have positive effects on
things like cancer and arthritis like
very real Parkinson stuff I mean so it's
like these could act this could actually
be a beneficial alternative treatment
that is actually saving taxpayers money
and helping people at the same time I'm
all for it um right so we're we're
pretty much all agreed here yeah we're
all agreed on the weed uh do you think
years from now that the people that are
against legalizing weed forget this the
the poor person angle here but the
people that are still fighting it now
are they gonna be looked back on and
just thought of as totally ridiculous I
mean yeah we're probably gonna look back
on them in the same way we look back on
people who were all for the prohibition
yeah you know I mean freedom freedom
right um yes free love free love there
you go